foreign
I love these movies
[Music]
so John Wick chapter 4 is the fourth
chapter in what we call the absolutely
amazing John Wick series after the
events of chapters two and three the
table it's pretty much the John Wick
Illuminati they're the the Council of
this underworld of Assassins they want
John Wick dealt with Phil Skarsgard
plays the one leading that charge and
now John Wick who for two movies now has
heard that beep beep beep sound in his
ear because he's been at minimal HP he's
licked his wounds he's healed up now
he's back to full HP and now yes he's
here to play you want to hear about the
action right well we gotta talk about
the characters first first of all I mean
I'm convinced Keanu is the only one who
could keep this franchise going this
long because he's he's so Keanu on
screen in a way that no one else could
be
yeah I would be shocked if I learned he
had more than 10 lines in this entire
film but
I kind of see his character kind of see
John Wick as the penitent one in silence
and blasphemy as a game which I love
where is Blasphemous 2 information I
just want a trailer come on dependent
one he never talks but he is the vessel
taking the audience through this Odyssey
through this world of rules and lore and
it's kind of what John Wick is there are
supporting characters in this film which
Hammer home the dramatic moments John
Wick's language that he communicates
with the audience is one of action but
it's done so well it's a communication
that still does hit it's
it's a language all its own that they
absolutely nail in John Wick but the
support characters in this film I
thought were great Bill Skarsgard I will
use the word magnificent because that's
that's the kind of character he is he's
a magnificent character absolute douche
total prick in that John Wick kind of
world it's a world of fashion and Flair
big Cathedrals huge art galleries
amazing suits and that's why we watch it
and he's the guy who wears the most
expensive [__] but doesn't have one
tenth the class I thought he was great
Donnie and his character I felt lend
some complexity but also amazing
physicality because it's Donnie and in a
John Wick movie of course you're going
to use his physicality different
characters giving different fight Styles
the movie never feels redundant and
that's saying something 2 hour 45 minute
action film a two hour 45 minute action
film that's the fourth film in the
franchise also Donnie Yen plays a blind
badass like in Rogue one this is kind of
funny to me and it totally works it's
like oh blind Donnie Yen
so he's gonna [__] everyone up everyone
knows that they're about to shed their
mortal coil great as long as I know it
totally works for former Jedi and John
Wick characters that's kind of that's
the realm John Wick's playing with here
ever since the first John Wick when we
got to the Continental in the first John
Wick I was like there is something comic
book flavor in here and I love it let me
just slip into it like a warm bath and
four continues to play with it amazingly
also Shamir Anderson's character true
wild card also he has the dog he's the
dog element he's the one with the attack
dog that assists him because it's not a
John Wick film without a dog as for the
action sequences incredible I think is
putting it mildly because at this point
you feel like okay it's the fourth John
Wick movie
I've seen it all before but not like
this the John Wick movies do a good job
at escalation you know yeah in John Wick
movies before you've seen shootouts
you've seen hand-to-hand combat you've
seen hand weapon combat you've seen
human body versus automobile combat but
not like you've seen it in John Wick
chapter four it just does an incredible
job at making you feel like this is the
first time you've experienced a John
Wick film usually that's something that
the first sequel has to deal with like
how do we make two not feel like one
this is the fourth chapter the fourth
installment still feels new there was
actually an action sequence in here I
was like I said to the dude to the left
of me I know him don't worry it wasn't
weird
not like I was like Hey dude I never met
before I went dude this feels like a
video game and I meant that in the best
way possible and he replied it feels
like Hotline Miami my response was can I
use the video thank you Aaron I
appreciate it this is the perfect way to
describe it I was watching it I was like
this is Hotline Miami and I know what
you're thinking we've seen action
sequences I feel like Hotline Miami not
like this I never felt the two hour 45
minute run time at no point did I feel
like I was watching a movie that was
almost three hours it always had great
momentum it was always being pushed
forward and they used all of that time
to introduce characters that are
actually interesting characters you
wouldn't mind seeing in the future
possibly in spin-offs I know we're
already getting a spin-off about the
Continental I would not mind to spin off
about Donnie Yen's character John Wick
chapter four Nails it you know so often
in movies you see characters that feel
shoehorned into the movie to set up for
a spin-off that no one asked for but
that's the sole reason they're there
John Wick chapter four the characters
are interesting in the movie they make
sense in the movie and you want to see a
spin-off because you want to see more of
those interesting characters that's how
it should be in the end what they
delivered here wasn't just a John Wick
movie it's a John Wick Odyssey and John
Wick chapter 4 is a testament to the
John Wick films being among the cleanest
and most satisfying action films we get
in current Western Cinema as for the
negatives in John Wick chapter 4
well I guess that's that satisfying
that's the word for John Wick chapter
four or if you prefer
awesome tacular
it has the style the Flair and the world
of rules that we know and love from a
John Wick film also the action they know
the audience is craving at this point
they dial it up to 11. you know when
people say oh everything's bigger
doesn't necessarily mean better I don't
mind saying John Wick chapter 4 is
bigger and better than chapters two and
three all right so John Wick chapter
four have you seen it what did you think
about it or how do you rank the John
Wick films whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]